dort tobt seit tagen eine
schlammschlacht und ein echter
rosenkrieg zwischen johnny depp und
seine extra amber heard die genauen
details zu diesen prozess in london
kennt meine kollegin annika rage auch
heute ging es wieder vor gericht und was
kannst du uns sagen über diesen prozess
genau in dem prozess geht es ja um den
fall zwischen der britischen sun und
johnny depp johnny depp verklagt die sun
wegen verleumdung weil die behauptet
hätte hat dass er einen frauenschläger
sei und heute dieser tag heute das ist
der sechste prozesstag gewesen
davon könnte johnny depp auf jeden fall
profitieren denn eigentlich haben heute
nur leute ausgesagt die für ihn sprechen
unter anderem seinen bodyguard marco
brunelli der seit 16 jahren viel
arbeitet und gesagt hat ich habe nie
verletzungen an amber heard gesehen und
wenn dann wäre ich eingeschritten und
auch seine haushälterin terror roberts
die gesagt hat dass sie gesehen hat wie
mbh sich selbst mal auf johnny depp
gestürzt hat ihm an den haaren gerissen
hätte das problem heute war das auch
wieder eine fotos vorgelegt wurden von
johnny depp die ema hat selbst
aufgenommen hat mit denen sie zeigen
möchte wie schlimm der drogenmissbrauch
ihres ex mannes war zum beispiel ein
foto aus dem juli 2013 da sieht man
johnny depp neben seinem bett liegend
der kopf ist fast eingeklemmt unter
seinem nachttisch erträgt keine schuhe
und damit wollte sie zeigen dass es
nicht mal mehr ins bett geschafft hat
weil er vorher einen drogencocktail und
alkohol zu sich genommen hat daneben gab
es noch ein foto von eines tisches war
kokain vorbereitet hatte aber auch
gläser mit whiskey und dazu ein kleines
bisschen mit seinen initialen seine ex
frau amber und ihre schwester sollen
vier stunden lang versucht haben ihn von
diesem tisch wegzuziehen und haben es
nicht geschafft er selbst sagte dass das
ist eine lüge und er wäre neben dem bett
nur eingeschlafen
dann gab es aber auch ein foto von dem
flug von boston nach aus dem jahr 2014
da ist johnny depp auf dem sofa
eingeschlafen beziehungsweise
weggetreten denn auf seinem schoß liegt
ein umgekippter eisbecher das eis läuft
raus er selbst sagt er sei müde gewesen
sie sagt er habe zu viel drogen genommen
und vierte und letzte bild was noch mal
gezeigt
nein entschuldigung ich wollte ich nicht
unterbrechen
das letzte bild was gezeigt wurde war im
mai 2016
da soll er ein für ein iphone gegen ihr
auge geworfen haben im streit er sagt
aber dass das nicht stimmt und was ich
jetzt einmal noch zeigen will heute
morgen ist johnny depp ihr hinter mir an
der straße angekommen in einem mercedes
bus und dann den weg hier über die
treppe ins gerichtsgebäude gegangen
seine ex frau emma war schon zehn
minuten vorher im gericht die achten
beide immer penibel darauf dass sie
getrennt voneinander hier am gericht
ankommen und möglichst nicht
aufeinandertreffen also auch in den
letzten tagen sind sie nie aufeinander
getroffen sein weil immer darauf
geachtet wurde dass johnny depp da links
durch den haupteingang geht und amber
heard durch den nebeneingang und die
beiden leben hier in london aber
ziemlich nah beieinander
rund 15 fußminuten schlafen sie getrennt
voneinander könnten sich theoretisch
also fast besuchen oder über den weg
laufen
und hier gucken wir jetzt einmal drüber
durch den eingang ist amber heard heute
morgen gegangen und hier warten jetzt
die paparazzi und fotografen
gerade weil ich glaube in diesem moment
sogar johnny depp mit seinem silbernen
wagen raus fahren konnte der prozesse
seit einer stunde vorbei und jetzt
scheint es ganz so als würde johnny depp
losfahren genau in dem auto ist er
vorhin auch angekommen in einem
silbernen mercedes v klasse
und genau jetzt fährt er raus also rund
eine stunde nach ende des prozesses am
hut hat das gerichtsgebäude vorhin schon
verlassen
schon vor ungefähr einer dreiviertel
stunde und jetzt die wegen dem zu die
fans aber leider kann man nichts sehen
die scheinbaren zu verdunkelt jetzt
fährt er weg in sein hotel das
wahrscheinlich dass rund 1,5 kilometer
von hier entfernt ist und genau der
prozess geht jetzt noch bis zum 27
die tage in den nächsten tagen für ihn
ausgehen werden weiß man nicht auf jeden
fall wird morgen seine ex freundin
winona ryder aussagen und bisher heißt
ist dass sie auf jeden fall für ihn
sprechen wird vielen dank an ikarus live
aus london dankeschön